optional fabulous well Adele could take
home five Grammys when the show airs
this sunday on CBS and she's already the
big winner on the new Forbes list at the
highest earning Grammy nominees Adele
tops of all raking in 80 point five
million dollars last year but who is
going to look like a million bucks on
Graeme night while Cameron Madison at
that cover hey guys I'm hanging out in
the absolute lime green room absolute
partnered with the Grammys this year to
celebrate the launch of their newest
flavor Absolut Limon we teamed up with
them to build this great space to come
in hang out and talk every single gram
is now where is one of our favorite
Grammys topic the fashion of course
because nothing is off limits on that
red carpet I mean you see stars with
look that you would not see literally
anywhere else you can't talk about the
grammy red carpet without bringing up
lady gaga her style statement sudanese
is go big or go home from that
futuristic Armani Prive a gown accented
with giant hoax to last year's electric
blue culture as she warned honor of
David Bowie and no one could forget yet
came in on an egg and you came in with
with an egg one my hardest thursday i
couldn't even sit down in the sdb i had
to like food I didn't want it to get
smushed Nicki Minaj is another Grammy
fashion restasis in 2011 she mix fierce
the Bride of Frankenstein and the next
year she chose a bright red Versace
styled none had and Nikki likes poker
game JD fairies mint green Gucci gown
was so wild would even made Ellen
DeGeneres's jaw drop and none of us did
on seeing Matador outfit wearing Madonna
who flashed her bare bottom at the crowd
totally didn't care because
Burrell's Grammy hat made a statement
and it God's own Twitter account less
than half an hour after we walked the
carpet it also sparked underneath and
who knew Cher wore that cut down to the
belly button style 26 years before JLo
change fashion history in that green
Versace gown I felt like an energy like
everything started stirring it was is a
weird feeling sounds like what's
happening my dress was happening and I
didn't know it now there's obviously a
lot of green in here but what's going to
be the color trend on the grammys red
carpet just going to have to wait till
Sunday and find out now also keep an eye
out for a little surprise from absolute
line they seemed up with recording
artist song see gold for their refresh
the top campaign put a little twist on
this year's red carpet conversation
we're also you'll be talking about Katy
Perry because the Grammys announced that
she is going to perform and john legend
is going to be a part of the in memoriam
tribute and of course we broke the news
first Beyonce who is pregnant with twins
is performing at the graph
you